you may be asking yourself or at least I
hope you're asking yourself hey but what
about air handling I didn't see a dot
error method on the end of that call and
you're right because unfortunately air
handling isn't actually built into JSON
P this is a technical limitation because
of what's happening behind the scenes
but there are workarounds like what
we're doing here we can use set timeout
to stop the request if it runs for too
long before we run this Ajax request
we'll create this set timeout function
well we bind wiki request timeout to
this set timeout function we
automatically start a timer that will
end 8000 milliseconds later which is
eight seconds when eight seconds are up
we'll go ahead and change the text of
the wiki element on the page to fail to
get Wikipedia resources this is a nice
fallback this says that if after eight
seconds have gone by change the text on
the page to this but of course there's a
problem if this is all we did we would
no matter what overwrite the text inside
the Wikipedia element with failed to get
Wikipedia resources after eight seconds
in other words even if this Ajax request
came back successful this timeout would
still occur these eight seconds would
still pass by and the text of the wiki
element would still change to fail to
get Wikipedia resources so we have to
add this line here called clear timeout
and then pass it the variable name of
the timeout we created up here which is
wiki request timeout this clear timeout
will clear or stop this timeout from
happening so inside our success method
we go ahead and append all the articles
to the page and then say hey stop that
timeout we don't need that timeout
anymore and then it's all good there are
a few different ways we can handle
errors with JSON P requests but I
thought this is a pretty easy way of
doing it